Are all cultures equal? That is, after
all, the taken forranted premise behind
the widely accepted notion of
multiculturalism, a belief that has
single-handedly led to the infusion of
countless cultures into the West. I was
reminded about this question while
recently thinking about the passing of
Pope Francis. I recalled how once while
apologizing to indigenous peoples for
all the horrible things Christians did
to them throughout the centuries, the
late pope declared that quote, "Never
again can the Christian community allow
itself to be infected by the idea that
one culture is superior to others." This
widely held position is very dangerous
specifically because it leads to
relativism and the abnigation of truth.
The problem is that for most Western
people today, the word culture conjures
up superficial differences, exotic dress
or food. In reality, however, cultures
are nothing less than entire and
distinct world views with their own
unique sets of right and wrong, often
rooted in a religion or philosophy.
Indeed, for some thinkers such as TS
Elliott, culture and religion are
inextricably linked and quote, different
aspects of the same thing, he wrote,
adding, culture may even be described
simply as that which makes life worth
living. No culture can appear or develop
except in relation to a religion. We can
see a religion as the whole way of life
of a people. His emphasis from birth to
the grave, from morning to night, and
even in sleep. And that way of life is
also its culture. That's from TS
Elliot's book notes towards the
definition of culture. Similarly for
Anglo French historian Hilera Bellock.
Quote cultures spring from religions.
Ultimately the vital force which
maintains any culture is its philosophy,
its attitude toward the universe. The
decay of a religion involves the decay
of the culture corresponding to it.
We see this most clearly in the
breakdown of Christendom
today. He made these observations nearly
a century ago. What one wonders would he
say today? At any rate, the point here
is that cultures bring much more than
say the convenience of having Thai
cuisine down the street. Which leads to
another important fact. All those
cultural traits prized by the modern
west today, religious freedom,
tolerance, humanism, gender as in male
and female only, equality, did not
develop in a vacuum. but are rather
byproducts of Christian principles and
ethics which over the course of some
2,000 years have had a profound
influence on Western epistemology,
society and of course culture. While
these values are now taken for granted
and seen as universal, there's a reason
why they were born and nourished in
Christian, not Muslim, Buddhist, Hindu
or Confucian nations. Even if one were
to accept the widely entrenched
narrative that the Enlightenment is what
led to Western progress, it is alone
telling that this enlightenment arose in
Christian as opposed to any of the many
non-Christian nations that I just
mentioned. All this is missed by those
ignorant of the spiritual and
intellectual roots of Western
civilization. Many secular people in the
West arrogantly see themselves as the
culmination of all human history.
enlightened thinkers who have left all
cultural and religious baggage behind
with concern only for that which matters
namely the material. For them all
religions and cultures are
superficialities that will eventually be
shed off by all the peoples of the
world. The non-western world according
to this way of thinking is destined to
develop just like the west which is no
longer seen as a distinct culture but
rather as the end point of all cultures.
The folly of such thinking is especially
on sharp display in the context of Islam
and Muslims who in this new paradigm are
seen as embriionic westerners. Whatever
a Muslim may say calls for jihad, hate
for infidels, surely deep down inside he
values secularism and appreciates the
need to practice Islam privately,
respect religious freedom, gender
equality and so on. So goes this
thinking. Thus he is made in our image
except of course we forget the roots of
our image. In reality, the Muslim has
his own unique and ancient worldview and
set of principles, his own culture,
which in turn prompt behavior that is
deemed radical by Western standards,
which are falsely assumed to be
universal standards. As TS Elliott, who
obviously gave these questions much
thought, wrote, quote, ultimately
antagonistic religions must mean
antagonistic cultures, and ultimately
religions cannot be reconciled.
Portraying what at root is a byproduct
of Christian teaching as universal and
then applying it to an alien culture
like Islam is doomed to failure. The
idea that Muslims can be true to their
religion and yet naturally fit into
Western society is false and built on an
equally false premise that Christianity
somehow also had to moderate itself to
fit into secular society. In fact,
Christian principles which are so alien
to Islam were fundamental to the
creation of the West. So what then of
multiculturalism? this word that the
west is supposed to continue celebrating
and embracing wholeheartedly as seen
behind it is the idea that all cultures
are equal and none certainly not
Christian or western culture is superior
to others again to quote the dearly
departed pope in reality
multiculturalism is another euphemistic
way of undermining and replacing the
truths of a religion and its culture
namely Christianity with relativism
earlier western peoples understood that
capitulating to a foreign culture was
tantamount not to suicide. Thus, and to
quote again from TS Elliott, quote, "It
is inevitable that we should when we
defend our religion be at the same time
defending our culture and vice versa. We
are obeying the fundamental instinct to
preserve our existence." This again is
from his book notes towards the
definition of culture. One anecdote well
captures this clash of cultures. After
the British colonial powers banned Sati,
the Hindu practice of burning a widow
alive on her husband's funeral p, Hindu
priests complained to British governor
Charles James Npir that Sati was an
important part of their culture and
therefore their right. To which he
replied, quote, "Be it so. This burning
of widows is your custom. Prepare the
funeral p." But my nation has also a
custom. When men burn women alive, we
hang them and confiscate all their
property. My carpenters shall therefore
erect gibbits on which to hang all
concerned when the widow is consumed.
Let us all act according to our national
customs. Rather refreshing, right, when
men used to talk like that. By the way,
being opposed to multiculturalism, that
is to say, relativism, is in no way the
same thing as being opposed to other
races or ethnicities, but rather being
opposed to social disunityity and chaos.
After all, racially homogeneous but
culturally heterogeneous nations are
much more fractured than the reverse.
One need look no further than to the
United States, where leftist and
rightest whites often opport one
another. Or look to the Middle East,
where Muslims and Christians are largely
homogeneous racially, ethnically, and
linguistically, but where the former are
ruthlessly persecuting the latter
exclusively over religion. In short,
there's nothing wrong if a nation's
citizenry is composed of different races
and ethnicities, but only if they share
in the same world view, the same
priorities, the same ethics, the same
sense of right and wrong. In a word, the
same culture.